it's the big difference between the
athletes and the investment
professionals I mean I think the big
difference is not so much between the
people is it is the situation so
investing their training is just wildly
different than sports you know first of
all but the point is Forks is to make
something happen like you physically
make something happen the point of
investing or trading is to set yourself
up for something to happen it's a
completely different environment you you
know the game ends you either won or
lost like it's clear you know the ball
goes backwards it's not good in
investing the game never ends the ball
goes backwards I don't know is that
should you get out or as an opportunity
like there's a level of ambiguity in
investing is you know orders of
magnitude greater than it is in sports
which makes investing a lot lot lot
harder than sports but as far as the
people themselves you know athletes are
playing a team sport think of the world
in terms of the people like just like
the best investors to the athletes that
that are in the individual sports like
the New York Times did an article about
Lindsey Jacobellis and me she's
snowboard racer you know that's me
well she's racing games for other people
and she just actually think a lot about
other people and how she's would be
anything like a pitcher I've been
working with you know that's thinking
about other people you know I think I'm
in some ways I'm like everyone's human
and everyone's brain works like human
being and I'm at risk of sounding
whatever they're all the same to me but
but I do think very much what situation
in there like three years ago I had a
general manager
a baseball team called me that I watched
more baseball the following two weeks I
watched in the proceeding like fifty
years of my lives because I wanted and
what does it feel like to be standing at
second base you know what I always think
like all I mean I've said sometimes what
does it feel like to you you know what
is it that's what I want to know because
I want to help them sort through that so
they're able to operate out of the
feelings that are helping them and
giving them information and able to
avoid the ones that aren't